today on campaign check the
Conservatives plans for social care
Boris Johnson was very clear when he
took office that it was a priority we
will fix the crisis in social care once
and for all with a clear plan we have
prepared to give every older person the
dignity and security they deserve that
was then but do natori still have a plan
and what is it well not according to
their manifesto which only commits to
seek cross-party support for an
unspecified plan that would mean no one
has to sell their home to pay for care
it also promises an extra billion pounds
a year to tackle the short-term funding
crisis now Social Care matters because
we're all living longer by 2060 620
point 4 million people will be over 65
that's one in four of the population and
Social Care is means-tested so only
those with total assets of less than 23
thousand two hundred and fifty pounds
receive free care which leaves the
majority facing a lottery with
potentially huge costs for conditions
like dementia and in the last 20 years
more than three hundred and thirty
thousand people have had to sell their
homes to pay for care now this chart
shows Social Care spending since 2010
and the impact the extra 1 billion
pounds would have over the next four
years you can see it's still three point
six billion pounds short of keeping up
with rising demand and wages and it is
way off the eleven point seven billion
pounds required to restore Social Care
Services to pre austerity levels now for
context we can compare it with the other
party's promises there's the
Conservatives 1 billion pounds this is
the Liberal Democrats promising 2.9
billion pounds but even Labour's offer
of 11 point 1 billion isn't enough to
drag standards back to 2010 levels now
the central point the conservative
manifesto avoids is that if homeowners
are to be protected and somebody else
has got to pay Boris Johnson has ruled
out raising income tax so one option
might be compulsory social insurance
that's effectively a new tax you can
impose a cap on how much people would
have to pay or national insurance could
be extended to pension income but all of
these involve difficult choices and the
Conservatives remember well how to read
Mays election campaign was derailed by
this issue there is no cheap simple
answer and in this election the
Conservatives haven't really tried to
find one solving the social care crisis
is as much a question of political
appetite as of economics